Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
Thank you very much.
And my question is regarding Adhd,
which is something I haven't
heard you speak a whole lot about,
maybe a little bit.
Um,
now it seems to me that we
are at least maybe just me,
do not quite understand ADHD to what
could be its full capacity maybe.
And uh,
cause there's many,
many voices saying that it's
an overdiagnosed overblown
small mental variance
that's prevalent in boys or it's
just young boys being young boys.
And then there are some that would
fight and advocate for a very different
treatment in the academic world.
Um,
and I was wondering what you,
what your thoughts are on Adhd itself.
Um,
and on,
uh,
the,
whether you think it's overdiagnosed and
maybe advice for me as someone who has
been diagnosed with ADHD on
how to overcome it without
maybe becoming completely
reliant on prescribed medication.
Okay.
So first of all,
it's definitely overdiagnosed.
Second,
it's,
it's very unreliable.
Psychiatric diagnosis.
Many psychiatric diagnosis are
unreliable and that's because psychiatric
diagnosis aren't precisely
scientific categories.
They're weird hybrids,
right?
First of all,
psychiatrists aren't scientists.
They're engineers.
Engineers are trying to do
something rather than to
describe the objective world
and psychiatrists are trying
to make people healthy,
whatever that means.
It's actually partly ethical.
It's very complicated.
Okay.
We don't know how to distinguish
it from temperamental variation.
So for example,
if you're high in openness and
high in extroversion and low in
conscientiousness,
yeah,
low in agreeableness,
conscientiousness and
and high in neuroticism,
you're likely to manifest
symptoms of Adhd.
It's because your exploratory,
you don't like to sit down,
you're full of ideas,
your attention scatters across a wide
variety of topics and you're not very
stable,
temperamental variation.
It's also much more common among boys.
Um,
Panksepp showed same guy with rats that
if you deprive young routes of rough and
tumble play,
which is what the young boys
are deprived of in school,
let's say that,
uh,
they get hyperactive and
then their prefrontal cortex
is don't develop very well
because they're not having the right kinds
of experiences and that you can treat
that quite effectively with
psychomotor stimulants like Ritalin.
So that's kind of an interesting bit of
scientific information that no one pays
any attention to.
There was also absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that longterm use of
psychomotor stimulants produces increases
in cognitive gate zero and there's
plenty of evidence that it's harmful.
So
then the second part
of that was what about,
yeah,
adjustments for in the academic world
say that would be disability adjustments.
It's like that's a such a rat's nest
that I don't want to even discuss it.
I mean it it,
I'll discuss it for like 15 seconds.
There is a never ending
multiplication of disabilities.
That's what's happening right now.
The disability offices in
the universities are swamped.
Like I know some people
have it rough like,
believe me,
I know that I was,
I prob,
I seriously know that I've dealt with
extraordinarily damaged people in my life.
[inaudible] you're bloody hard pressed
to find someone who doesn't have a
serious problem or who doesn't have a
serious problem in a close family member.
It's like,
where do you draw the line
with regards to disability?
Well,
you can't,
you can't.
They multiply just like
LGBT identities multiply.
Just know g really
technically just like that.
Just like intersectionality
categories of oppression multiply.
It's,
it's,
it's inevitable the way
that you deal with it.
As you have objective standards,
you apply them to everyone.
Not because that's fair.
It's not fair.
If you,
if your criteria for fairness is
that everyone has the same outcome,
it's not fair at all.
It's not even close to fair.
It's just less tie radical
then the alternatives.
Now we don't know that yet because we
haven't seen the full range of the tyranny
of the alternatives manifest itself.
Not In our culture,
but it certainly did in other cultures.
I think it's a bad idea now.
I don't want to be absolute about that.
Like
it's tricky,
you know,
because if you have a disability
that
would allow you to do the work in the
university and in the workplace with a
modification,
then perhaps the
modification could be made.
But I think that was done a lot better
when I was in the hands of the professors
and not in the hands of these crazy
bureaucratic structures that have risen up
around the disability issue.
Like they're one of the 10 things that
are going to kill the universities or
maybe have already killed them,
possibly because they may,
they're walking corpses as
far as I can tell zombies,
so,
and that might be wrong,
but is what it looks like to me.